today I'm cooking hearty food recipes
with the generous helping of warmth
comfort and Indulgence
it's honest food with big and satisfying
flavors that really grab your taste buds
and makes no apologies so when you want
to welcome your friends or family back
home after a nice long walk or an
exhausting football match these are the
recipes to do it with this is my
ultimate hearty food
first up a hearty breakfast of smoked
haddock with spinach baked eggs
that that's beautiful for lunch the
ultimate comfort of a hearty creamy
tomato soup
that's delicious
served with Rich and delicious Welsh
rare bit
look at those babies that just takes
cheese and toast to another level
and my youngest daughter Tilly joins me
making beef and Ale stew with mustard
dumplings
and that's the only way I want you to
taste beer
followed by a scrumptious pear and
Ginger galette
three delicious full-bodied comforting
meals breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with a hearty breakfast of
smoked haddock and spinach baked eggs
this boat haddock one of my favorite
fish delicious
highly sustainable it's packed with
protein lightly smoked there's not a Dye
smoke there's a big difference see I've
got that bright yellow tinge
so much better
next baby spinach there's a spinach
that's very young full of zinc great
flavor a little teaspoon volleyball knob
of butter
that little touch of oil stops the
butter from burning
it looks like a lot of spinach
but it's going to disintegrate almost by
two-thirds when I'm cooking spinach and
butter open up the top of my pepper
Mills so the pepper becomes almost like
so Cracked Pepper not so fine
once your spinach has reduced down by
two-thirds add in your cubes of smoked
haddock
tag them it's got that nice vinegary
flavor quite tart
pick off the little buds from the stalks
keep all of these and grateful when
you're making a tag of vinegar red wine
vinegar tag and stalks in
chop the target into your creme fraiche
little season
now grain mustard goes brilliantly well
with haddock
incredible this mustardy Herby creme
fresh will work equally well partnered
with grilled chicken the haddock's
starting to flake because it's smoked
lightly cured it Cooks so quickly you
creme fresh
now it's almost like the beginning of
the perfect fish pie but as opposed to
putting pastry on top the eggs are going
to bake on top so you've got this
wonderful egg crust
turn the gas off
now
crack your eggs around the outside
just a little twist of pepper get the
remainder of your creme fresh and put a
little dollop in between that adds
richness to the egg whites into the oven
at 180
for 10 to 12 minutes
[Music]
what's the haddock and eggs baked
together I can knock up a simple spring
onion garnish
in professional kitchen chefs refuse to
use the top of the spring onions but I
love that nice dark green flavor it says
harsh than the white the smell of baked
mustard you can't beat
[Music]
that is beautiful
spinach has almost melted in with a had
it now just sprinkle your spring onions
that gives that really nice sharpness
My ultimate hearty breakfast smoked
haddock and spinach baked eggs so packed
with protein and iron you'll be raring
to dive into the day ahead
[Music]
for my ultimate hearty lunch and dinner
you need some hearty ingredients
here's a more in-depth look at some of
the key ones you'll need to buy
made from roasted malt hops water and
yeast Stout Porter was the preferred
Bevy of London's River Porters in the
18th century
but this bridge bitter tasting beer is
linked with food goes way back too
not only is it the perfect hearty Tipple
to wash down a couple of oysters it
works its magic in soups stews pies and
cakes too
thank you
so it's a classic English ingredient
since the Middle Ages
half waxy fat is taken from around the
kidneys and loins of beef or mutton
today so it is still prized for
imparting a unique lightness and Rich
but subtle flavor to Savory and sweet
steamed puddings
and today I'll be rolling up traditional
mustard suet dumplings to hearty up a
slow-cooked beef stew
[Music]
Ginger a zingy and versatile medicinal
and culinary heavyweight
used powdered it adds punch to cakes
biscuits and beer crystallized is eaten
as lip smacking sweet meat
and the fresh or pickled fibers root
adds vibrant heat to dishes the length
and breadth of Asia I'll be using a
triple Ginger measure to give depth and
spice to wonderful classic pear and
Ginger galette
[Music]
when it comes to my ultimate hearty
lunch it's got to be soup soups can be
light and delicate or Rich and gutsy
they're versatile practical and easy to
make and for my ultimate hearty lunch
I'm making one of my childhood favorites
roasted tomato soup
beautiful Vine Tomatoes The Ripe in the
tomatoes the better the soup take the
core out get your thumb and place it
half a centimeter underneath the tip of
your knife place it in and then just
twist around that's the only part of the
Tomato that we're not using red onion
and garlic Red Onion because it's
sweeter than a white onion
slice your onions and your garlic
nice and fine traditionally we make it
in a pot it's so much better to start it
off on top of the stove searing the
tomatoes and the garlic but it goes in
the oven you actually roast the tomatoes
and they don't stew there's a big
difference in flavor be quite generous
with the olive oil it makes the soup
nice and glossy shiny salt pepper and
then a little teaspoon of cayenne just
gives it that heat but it's not as
Fierce as chili
take your Tomatoes just slice them in
half
and then
a little touch of sugar that's gonna
help intensify the sweetness
a little sprinkle of aged off with
vinegar gives that nice dark Rich
acidity to the soup
into the oven 20 25 minutes 180.
to make my soup even more irresistible
I'm going to make a Punchy sun-dried
tomato pesto to drizzle over the top
now I'm making this in a pestle and
mortar because you feel so much more in
control and you're not depending on a
blade that's whizzing around a thousand
miles an hour
next in a dry pan toast off some pine
nuts
toast them the absolute Max and then in
smelling those incredible
parmesan
slightly grate that
this is where it starts to become creamy
extra virgin olive oil
doesn't need salt because the parmesan
is going to season it for you
and just take a couple of tablespoons of
the oil the sun-dried tomatoes are in
really helps to make that stunning pesto
I can smell those roasted tomatoes I
want them out
wow
next pour in a little vegetable stock or
chicken stock so it sits halfway up the
tomatoes
put your spoon through those Tomatoes
they break up instantly bring that up to
the boil let it simmer for three or four
minutes
I want to make a little bit more
creaming out creaming
give that a little stir you can keep it
rustic and get your Masher in and you've
got that nice thick Rich Chunky Tomato
Soup
or give yourself a stick blender
[Music]
blitzing it like that you deglaze the
bottom of the pan and you get all those
amazing flavors from the bottom
um
that's delicious
to make my lunch extra hearty I'm going
to knock up a deliciously gutsy version
of cheese on toast to go with my tomato
soup watch Rabbit an absolute classic
I'm gonna make a roux 50 pounds of
butter three nice tablespoons of flour
and that's all the roux is basically
traditionally you would use flour butter
and milk
but in Welsh rabbit the milk is often
cheekily substituted for a stiff slug of
stout it gives it that strong gutsy
flavor
I want it nice and thick make sure those
lumps are out
a nice teaspoon of Dijon mustard and
then season it
nice and spicy with Worcestershire sauce
gives it that delicious intriguing
Flavor now that smells amazing
almost brings tears to your eyes
beautiful
now whilst rabbit wouldn't be a stunning
Welsh rabbit without Rich mature cheese
so I'm a great
Montgomery cheddar goes well with the
beer
and drop that in really important to put
this in by the roux still nice and hot
because the cheese melts
now for the bread
I prefer a good rustic country loaf that
will stand up to my hardcore topping
I want that nice crisp base to my Welsh
rabbit so toast it both sides
[Music]
spread that beautiful cheesy Berry spicy
mixture just great
got a blister
and bubble and gratinate
God
a little splash alien Perry
and back under the grill for 90 seconds
in one delicious
creamy roasted tomato soup it's coming
back to me all those days I had off
school I used to purposely lie about
feeling ill just to get a bowl of my
mother's tomato soup
how bad was that but my God it was worth
it oh
now my Welsh rabbit
look at those babies that just takes
cheese on toast to another level
wow roasted creamy tomato soup with a
sun-dried tomato pesto served with the
most amazing delicious Welsh rabbit
I feel like bringing in sick
[Music]
some of the best hearty dinners I can
think of are slow cooked recipes made
with robust deep flavored ingredients
and left to Bubble away for hours until
they become glossly rich this is the
sort of food that really gives you
plenty of energy and protects you
against cold winter weather so for my
ultimate Hearty dinner I'm doing a dish
that every home cook should have a
recipe for a great stick to your ribs
stew here's my favorite beef and Ale
with mustard dumplings
foreign
[Music]
first things first I'd like you to
season the students day
a nice spoon of flour
mix yeah
good girl what's the flower going to do
dad the flower helps to Brown the beef
seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor and thicken the stew I feel a bit
like marshmallows you do feel a little
bit marshmallow don't they look at the
size of the chunks of the beef
I'm gonna cut my carrots literally
similar similar sizes right does that
mean they'll cook equally that's right
now these they're little pearl onions
I'm going to put them in whole as well
everything has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn oh we've seen
burn garlic before
Oh Matilda
I should probably mention that
what is that
time time and what they
Bailey's Bailey's good girl tablespoon
of oil in the beef goes in first okay in
now really nice color it's a beautiful
color
remember the carrots thyme in good girl
garlic pearl onions in good
give that a really good mix up
[Music]
shoes are very easy to make providing at
the beginning you give it a little bit
of love
now that's all juicy browned
that bear that is beer and that's going
to deglaze the pan adding beer or Stout
helps to tenderize the beef and give it
a hearty delicious flavor
and that's the only way I want you to
taste beer
in a stew
yeah
I'm going to add in a couple of
teaspoons of tomato puree please
in fact three please because it's so
nice and there's one final thing in
there cover this tuna steak with a big
stock give that a little mix with Daddy
please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you start um serve it
oh yes is the Garlic going to be burnt
no excuse me
right the wheels put the lid with a
little bit just a little bit so it can
be trying to not make the stew or watery
into the oven at 150 please tell us for
about two and a half hours and now
getting focused on your homework
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato Classics in one twice baked
bubble and sweet jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
we shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute and butter and add a dash of
water until tender
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and
cooked through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato Center
then Mash with a couple of knobs of
butter or mix in the cabbage and season
to taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato Classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
right homework done yeah
mysterious chewing stewing let's get on
with our delicious hearty pet tart I've
been looking forward to this you and I
Chef I'm gonna prep the pears so if you
peel I'll top and tell into quarters
pears go soft in the oven very very
quickly so we're going to put them on a
tart we'll need to leave them whole half
or in quarter what's that in there
Ginger that's right a stem Ginger so
when you use stem Ginger and fresh
ginger next add your stem Ginger a
little of the stem ginger syrup good
girl and some brown sugar to your
quartered pears
and then just grate some fresh ginger
off you go so it's a bit of a different
one to grate this because it doesn't
really come through like the cheese no
I'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there right what we need to do
now is give that
a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff we can make it so easy to do
so give me your finger that's my center
point I want you to get the pears going
around like that in a really nice Circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pairs keep on sliding all over the place
yeah
so egg wash the outside and I'm going to
show you a little trick so you lift that
up so see egg wash acting like a bit of
a glue that's right crimple this but
pastry form this nice little shelf like
a little money bag are you going to do
anything with the spare pairs oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
we've got the fresh ginger and those
nice little bits of stem Ginger let me
go around Mike with your glue we might
glow just on top
Tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully
it's a bit like snow isn't it now that
glazes the pastry so the pastry has this
really nice shine on there as well
finally the lemon on top
put that there
180 and in she goes
can you smell the beef
[Music]
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it
okay I want you to just I was hoping
you'd asked
taste
[Music]
how's that taste now
you're not allowed anymore
all right dumpling time flowering please
I'm using self-raising flour for a
fluffy result but if you like your
dumplings hard use plain flour next The
Dumpling essential suet that makes the
dumplings nice and moist
[Music]
by a generous dollop of grain mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers round Another
Touch of warm water here
your fingers are now a nice little whisk
fingers are getting tired right now put
your hand in there now you should bring
all that dough together
actually the best way to get that nice
and clean sprinkles and flour on your
hands rub them together
all that will come off
it's a good way is it now we've got this
wonderful dumpling mixture how squid is
that oh
a little flower on your hands okay roll
these blend ways
and then I want you to follow my lap in
your hand
I'll figure
smell that mustard in there
huh
come on
ever trust you or something like that
yes please silly
gently let's go in at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center
and put that back into the oven
for 20 minutes to cook the dumplings now
if you open the door for daddy I'm going
to take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our petard has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby
foreign would you like me to start
testing yes please
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job now very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look delish okay I'll
check on the dumplings
now look they've sort of doubled in size
well definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
I might have to have a quick taste
before we go just to check I mean we
have to be sure
[Music]
that is an amazing hearty beef stew
dumpling smoke the twice baked loaded
potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate Hearty dinner a
comforting Rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and Ginger galette
ready for some delicious beef stew yeah
oh wow thank you very much delicious
thank you will we be able to heat this
up for mum and Jack when they come back
easy even two or three days later toasty
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
foreign
over the years I've had great fun being
rude about vegetarians but today I'm
joining them I put together a fantastic
breakfast lunch and dinner packed with
amazing tastes textures and full-on
flavor without a bit of meat in sight I
guarantee My ultimate vegetarian food
will have even the most committed
Carnival drooling and begging for more
first up a real treat of a meat-free
breakfast pear and crunchy granola
muffins
for the perfect vegetarian lunch crispy
golden halloumi courgette and Herb cakes
halloumi cheese doesn't look that tasty
but once you've got color on it it's
really delicious and my youngest
daughter Tilly joins me in the kitchen
to make a scrummy three-course veggie
dinner that's my guilty pleasure is it
really courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto and for put white chocolate and
lime mousse with crushed raspberries
wow that looks really cool the on my
ultimate vegetarian recipes breakfast
lunch and dinner
first the perfect morning treat for
vegetarians and carnivores alike pear
and crunchy granola muffins
something quite nice when you walk into
friends or family's house and you smell
a muffin bean bags the flour and the
baking powder in a nice touch of
cinnamon
cinnamon muffins goes brilliantly pinch
of salt that's really important for the
sort of overall flavor you don't want
the muffin to be too sweet muscovado
sugar that's a refined brown sugar
really rich and somewhat spicy it goes
brilliantly inside the muffin and then
my crispy granola
so now we're gonna put half of this in
now and save the other half to sprinkle
on top of the muffin give that a really
good mix
in the center I have some fresh pear top
and tail of the pears really important
to peel nothing worse when you're trying
to enjoy that muffin and you're
negotiating with a big sliver
skin of pear
slice them around the core
sides
a slice them nice and thinly
generally muffins contain around half
the fat and sugar of cupcakes
once the dry ingredients are mixed
together you add in the wet
two whole eggs
nice milk in
followed by gently melted butter
give that a good mix
[Music]
add that to your mixture
start folding
always do it by hand muffins are
delicate dainty little beasts don't
overwork your muffin mixture you want
that mixture to become nice and relaxed
now the mix looks nice and creamy
you'll try
and your little cups
and Spoon in that mixture
two-thirds full
one nice generous spoon
and you can tell the mix is right
because you've got that even
distribution of the pear running from
the top to the bottom
just gently tap your tray both ends
that gets the mix all the way down so
they cook nice and evenly
take your granola now sprinkle that on
top so you've got this dual texture
spicy pear and this nice crunchy topping
makes the muffin taste and feel a little
bit more luxurious now into the oven at
180 for 25 minutes
uses
they smell delicious
got that nice crispy top just get them
out and let them cool down
and I don't have any problems turning
vegetarian once or twice a week
when I'm having muffins like that
nice
smell amazing
[Music]
a vegetarian breakfast to put hairs on
your chest pear and crunchy granola
muffins
that is a Vegetarian Delight beautiful
[Music]
coming up I'll be showing you a stunning
vegetarian lunch and dinner
but first here's a more in-depth look at
the key ingredients you'll need for them
first for dinner I'm using risotto rice
risotto is a flagship classic in Italian
cuisine but is widely believed that the
Spaniards introduced it to Northern
Italy back in the Middle Ages there are
three main types Arborio kanaroli and
violoni their ability to absorb liquid
and flavor whilst releasing lots of
starch is what makes risotto uniquely
delicious and anxious
a tasty creamy and inexpensive way to
satisfy lots of tummies without a morsel
of meat in sight
[Music]
the Deep dramatic red color of sweet
earthy beetroot makes it difficult to
outdo in terms of all-round culinary
impact
but early forms of this humble room veg
were carrot shapes and favored for their
medicinal rather than their cooking
merits today there is a veritable
rainbow of beetroot types to be enjoyed
pickled in soups grated into cakes or
even simply roasted which is how we're
using mine in my amazing vegetarian main
course risotto
halloumi is a firm springy salty cheese
with its roots firmly in Cyprus and
Greece
the better Lumi is made from sheep's
milk rich in vitamins and essential
nutrients is thought to promote
longevity
halloumi keeps for many months if stored
unopened in the fridge and its high
melting point makes it brilliantly
adaptable perfect for grilling barbecue
and frying I'll be championing this
texture lending Marvel for my yummy
vegetarian lunch dish of halloumi
courgette and Herb Cakes
[Music]
as a chef I'm never sniffy about cooking
with vegetables because I know that with
a bit of care and attention they can be
turned into something absolutely
stunning for my ultimate vegetarian
lunch I've got a couple of fantastic
recipes
lightly fried my delicious halloumian
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and Watercress salad
these cherry tomatoes are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes vegetable or
even just big normal plum tomatoes lay
the tomatoes on the tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes
if you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight to be honest
the longer you leave them the better
they taste
once you've seasoned them with salt
sprinkle over with some sugar
on the salt and sugar combined speeds up
the drying process because you want that
nice chewy texture and then you get
these little thyme flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact for 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything shrink down all
the Skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes
place your Tomatoes into an oven
preheated to 150 degrees C and cook long
and slow for an hour and a half
now halloumi cakes there's something
quite exciting about halloumi cheese
it's a very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
[Music]
peel the carrots
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette the secret is keeping it
all grated the same put that into a
sieve
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then grate the halloumi halloumi cheese
doesn't look that tasty but once you've
got color on it in the pan it's really
really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water in the veg and we'll see
all that water that needs to come out of
there if we didn't do this it'll make
your little patties non-friable because
the whole thing starts to separate and
then mix in with the cheese
spring onions chop up the whites and the
greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian I like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
and parsley minted coriander basil and
lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavors play off each other
next
two eggs in
give that a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture
and then finally a couple of tablespoons
of breadcrumbs the breadcrumbs help dry
out any excess moisture mix
all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now
if you wait until you've cooked them
it'll be too late to adjust the
seasoning
roll them to a large golf ball shape
them it's like a little mini burger
you can spice these up with some chili
in there if you haven't got fresh chili
chili flakes and it's something that can
be done up a day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes pan on get that
nice and hot boss and wait for that I'll
get the dressing ready
slice of red chili seeds and all on an
angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger
[Music]
season with a Sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar
add a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
[Music]
because that's sweet sour spicy flavor
with my chili dressing done I can start
frying off my halloumi cakes in a hot
oiled pan
look at that nice crisp Edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the courgettes and
carrots smells delicious really
important for a nice amount of color on
them
as my cakes Sizzle away I can finish off
with my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite leaves has to be the
Watercress just cut off stalks
[Music]
slot rings
Watercress and shallot go brilliantly
well together
looks so dainty when you open up these
little ringlets
[Music]
don't forget to turn your cakes
now Tomatoes whatever you don't use just
jar them and put them in the fridge
[Music]
just drop those slow cooked warm
Tomatoes over the Watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious a little drizzle of age of
ultimate vinegar gives that tartness to
the watercress
Watercress is naturally peppery so it
doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light sprinkling of extra
virgin olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready
so important to have taken out that
water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it and then tilt it to the side
because I want the garnish I don't want
the juice
but that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night I honestly don't know what
will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
Herb cakes with a Sumptuous roast tomato
and Watercress salad all of the flavor
with none of the meat
when I was growing up my mum was a very
very good cook so we had some great food
but it was always meat and two veg and
the veg definitely played a bit past but
the more attention you pay to cooking
vegetables the more you realize they can
easily take Center Stage for all the
flavor would know In the Flesh here's my
ultimate vegetarian dinner
first a hearty starter a bruschetta with
ricotta and succulent griddle courgettes
for my main I'm serving fragrant roasted
beetroot and Thyme risotto
[Music]
but I'll be in trouble with the kids if
I don't do it but
so I'm enlisting the help of my youngest
Tilly to rustle up an indulgent
chocolate and lime mousse with crushed
raspberries
so if you unwrap the chocolate start
breaking up in Little Bits we're going
to make the most amazing white chocolate
mousse our first job is to bring half of
our cream up to the boil so what kind of
cream is that in there dad that is
double cream okay so that's gonna make a
really nice rich chocolate mousse what's
your favorite sort of chocolate is it
white milk dark
um I love white and milk what's yours I
absolutely love milk chocolate
oh my guilty pleasure is it really here
we go cream end
so that goes in there now you can see
what's happening straight away can't you
it's melting really quickly melting
really quickly so okay oh excuse me at
least your Jumper's white so you won't
spot it yeah I've got a nice little snap
for later
in another Bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks the
lime cuts the sort of richness of the
cream and that starts to make the
chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter
mmm it smells really good the lime gives
it a really nice zinginess you're
absolutely right next add to the melted
chocolate mixture
because I'm whisking it's just getting
lighter and lighter and lighter
have a little taste
nice yeah the line gives it a really
nice taste Tilly I need the rest for the
mousse I need some for my tummy no come
on chocolate mousse into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites this is where I need you at
your absolute best okay because to whip
those whites it's going to be really
tough so we'll take it in turns 30
seconds each okay you go first
10 seconds gone
come on silly
in seconds gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three two one and change
excellent hold the ball right no no way
[Music]
you can't do that to me 30 seconds
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
you start tipping that sugar in slowly
should go
feeling all very happy in there so
a contentious whipped egg whites will
make our mousse light and Airy and when
they've reached soft peaks we can gently
mix in our cooled white chocolate and
cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yep
the chocolate sets the egg whites keep
the cream nice and fluffy and you get
this nice light mousse in the bowl now I
need you to crush some raspberries
please with some fresh mint
you can see all the juice coming out
now take your mousse
wow that looks really cool now look at
that down the bottom
it's a crushed raspberry delicious now
I'm going to set that in the fridge if
you use the can I open the door please
our yummy white chocolate mousse will
take at least two hours to set so we can
crack on with our Mediterranean inspired
vegetarian starter griddle courgette
Ricotta and mint bruschetta
for this recipe you'll need a griddle
pan an essential piece of kit for that
char grill look
cut thick slices of chapata bread
drizzle both sides with olive oil
[Music]
season with a little salt and pepper
and griddle each side until toasted
then slice a couple of courgettes
diagonally into half a centimeter thick
pieces drizzle and coat in olive oil and
season with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the courgettes are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy ricotta cheese
spread your toasty to your pattern with
dollops of minty Ricotta and top with
your seared courgette
super simple and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto we need to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto
shallots please into the pan for Daddy
add a Sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic once you start cooking the
risotto it's really important to have
your stock
gently boiling away if we're adding cold
stock on top of the rice all the time it
just slows down the process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you're cooking a deep pan all the
rice sort of Cooks at different
temperatures what stock is that in there
dad because that's a vegetable stock
yeah because you can't have different
stocks if it's for a vegetarian can you
no I made that mistake once putting beef
stock in the vegetarian soup
no I did and Matilda sure I'm positive
I'm joking
fly off the time how nice is that smell
s rice in
this is Arborio rice it's a perfect rice
for risotto now it's really important to
sear
the rice if we were just to put the
stock in without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for Daddy
no flambe on the risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
I'm adding red wine followed by the
first Ladle of stock to get things
started now we're off wow it's giving it
a cloudy sort of look
[Music]
what's happening to the stock
sock is reducing down and the rice is
sucking it in that's right so the rice
is actually getting nice and plump while
the risotto is live when it's like this
now we can't stop cooking it we have to
cook it all the way okay ready for the
next ladle
good girl here we go Ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way
eight words
killed him brought them a little bit of
salt and sugar yeah and a little bit of
aged bathroom vinegar in there roasted
them I'm a great
my parmesan
how's that Rice doing rice is doing good
no
no where you want to be now look at that
nice glossy textured rice so beetroot I
want you to put two thirds of the
beetroot in there for me saving one
third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
again and then we're just going to get
some nice butter in there the butter
gives the risotto a really nice gloss
look at that beautiful
come down let it come down first
and then after Daddy
beautifully there you go good wonderful
shaking risotto should be like lava
just
flows out and then the rest of the
beavery on top
[Music]
and some extra virgin olive oil
that I'll pick up the bruschetta you
take that to the table okay
let's go die
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta
an anxious roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto
and put an indulgent white chocolate and
lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries
a delicious non-meat feast that will
have vegetarians and carnivores fighting
for seconds tonight is vegetarian nights
Megan how is it really tasting I love it
I really liked making the risotto and we
had fun
so where's Holly
not very nice they hurt your ears
ears cheers everybody no meat vegetarian
vegetarians
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]